rooo and i left home and said i don't
want to be controlled no more like I
meant that like I don't want nothing to
control me but me and so I gotta put
myself under extreme discipline to make
sure I'm free if you want more
discipline in your life you need to hang
your own people who are very disciplined
my guaranteed formula for success that
is 100% proven for my life and other
people have taught
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's start your day off
where I grab your cup of coffee and sip
on today's message discipline yourself
over to you Eric Thomas as I was like yo
you got to discipline yourself
I started looking at mother Teresa of
Ghandi and I was like yo bro Gandhi
would go fast from sex and he was
married he would fast from talking you
know I just started watching these great
peoples like all these people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
peace but they were very disciplined
people and they would not allow their
exterior world to dominate or destroy
their internal world I just like you I
want to get to a place where I can
control me my family members have grown
a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking and I was like yo I do not want
to my father was a substance abuser for
years I was like yo I don't want a life
where something else is controlling me
you know like ruined I left home and
said I don't want to be controlled no
more like I meant that like I don't want
nothing to control me but me and so I
gotta put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free so when
people see me you get up at 3 you don't
drink you don't smoke I'm not doing that
because I think I'm better than a BYOs
oh I think you gonna go to hell because
you had a drink I just won't
I want to control I want freedom and for
me disciplining myself means more
freedom and
lest I you discipline yourself people
who I told my son other dads like your
son
I don't not want you to have fun I've
just seen a history of people who just
have fun Christmas Thanksgiving
Halloween know there are the people
learns they're nice Friday no man every
night the other people who end up in a
20s having a great deal of fun but in a
40s and 50s they were working for
somebody and I'm not saying I'm wrong
with cleaning toilets but they doing
something they don't want to do for the
rest of day life and they can't retire
because they played so much you know so
for me I just look at Venus in Serina
Michael Jackson when he used to like
five and six just dancing all night I
just think the more man discipline
himself the greater don't mean it's
gonna happen but the greater the
probability that he has this sense of
freedom if you look at anybody who's had
massive success in the world any of your
heroes your idols athletes entrepreneurs
musicians inventors politicians like
whoever it is that you look up to
getting to the top in any field comes
with a lot of discipline and hard work
it doesn't guarantee your success you
could be discipline to work hard and not
make it but nobody at the top has made
it without the discipline in the hard
work it's your ticket in it's a
necessity to get to be at the top if you
don't want a life at the top then don't
worry about it but if that's your
aspiration that's your goal you want to
be an industry leader it's gonna have to
come with discipline and hard work so
the next question for me then becomes
well how do you how do you get the
discipline how do you okay it's
important now how do I find it how do I
embrace it how do I use it daily because
that's the problem you're motivating
then you're not and then you're
motivating you're not how do you keep
the discipline going daily the two
things that keep coming to mind for me a
one is that you need to have the strong
y-you have to feel like what you're
doing is important you have to feel like
it's all working towards something
whatever that thing is that you want to
accomplish has to mean something really
important and powerful to you I'm a big
believer that the your purpose comes
from your pain for me why do I love
helping entrepreneurs
yes it's aspirational on that I think
entrepreneurs will solve all the world's
major problems I want to be a part of
that I want to contribute as much as I
can but the bigger reason is
I sucked as an entrepreneur getting
started it was the worst days of my life
I never felt so low and so useless and
so worthless in my life and when I got
through I just wanted to make it easier
for other people not to have to suffer
the same really days that I did I think
there's a lot of people who suffer that
you might know a thing or two about it
watching this and they never find a way
through and not to me was crazy I just
want to make it easy for the people so
and that's typical your pain becomes
your purpose
so whatever pain that you're struggling
with right now I get excited because
that means you're gonna have a really
strong purpose that means you're gonna
be able to help a lot of people once you
solve it once you get through it
you'll be to help others solve it too
and so the Y has to be strong enough why
are you putting yourself through even
more work it has to pay off somehow and
it's not just a monetary I can't just be
because I want to make money you won't
stick with it just to make money it's
got to be a deeper connection to a
purpose of what you're doing and so the
most disciplined people they have a Y
they have a strong why'd you should come
from police to pain that motivates them
to keep going every day the second thing
is your environment the things that are
around you the physical environment the
habits of people that you have around
you if you're around people who are
slacking off all day long it's gonna be
really really really hard for you to go
the opposite if you are around 18
slacker friends it's hard for you to be
the one person who's not a slacker
it's doable but it's really hard that's
why people who are from a certain
neighborhood they end up being like the
other people in that neighborhood you
just end up moulding to be like the
people around you so given that that's
what happens you need to change your
environment and circumstances to be
around people who are doing more who are
thinking like you want to be thinking if
you want more discipline in your life
you need to hang around people who are
very disciplined if you were hanging
around Eric Thomas all day long you
would be more disciplined and so listen
you can't hang around et all day long he
has other things happen in his life you
know he doesn't have an internship open
for you to go in and swap up and do but
it's never been easy to be hanging
around someone like that virtually right
watch a video he's got so much content
watch a video of his every day follow
him on Instagram or Twitter see what
he's posting consume it to the point
where again
you feeling discipline and then go do
your thing you're substituting out some
of your friends who are not disciplined
and keeping you where you are and you
have to kick them out of your life
completely you may want to but you may
not have to you could just be limiting
some exposure and then you free up time
and you spend that time with guys like
Eric with guys like Elon look I'd like
Steve with women like Oprah like you're
surrounding yourself with the people who
are doing the thing that you want to do
and the more you are hanging around them
even virtually which has never been
easier the more you will adapt those
mindsets the more you'll stop listening
to your friends and the more you'll go
for the thing that you want to do now
I've got a really special bonus clip for
you but first question today I want to
know what has been the hardest thing for
you to discipline yourself around I want
to know I want you leaving the comments
below
I want to hopefully by doing that now
you're gonna release it you got believe
nation cheering for you attach ego and
crush it leave it in the comments thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
the one thing that discipline definitely
does help you with is it helps you get
things done and when you get things done
when you you actually do things you you
you you have more success if you have
more success sometimes a big part of
success is just not being lazy and just
doing it yeah just get that's like 90%
of its just showing up get there and
start working like you're not gonna feel
perfect every day if I felt if I only
worked out when I felt good
I'd be a fat because there's a lot of
days I don't want to do it if it's
pretty much the same with everybody that
that actually gets good at something
that you you get there's got to be those
days you push through and they're
they're probably gonna be more numerous
than the days you don't and so the
benefit of discipline in my eyes has
always been that through discipline I
get things done I always tell my always
say that I'm like the most lazy
disciplined person I know because I
don't want to do it yeah but I always do
my guaranteed formula for success that
is 100% proven for my life and other
people have taught out work out improve
outlast and out strategies again out
work out improve outlast out strategize
what you're looking on the screen here
on the screen look at those four again
what you're looking on on the screen
here which of those four things that
you're looking at the out work out
improve outlets out strategize which of
those four things do you think comes
last meaning you'll learn the latter the
latest it's out strategize why because
that requires a lot of experience it's
like you got to go through like a
general in the war right you got to go
through so many different words to learn
different strategies and what works and
what tactics works and what doesn't work
that's something you got to be working
on right however the other three out
work if a guy works 80 hours a week and
you work 40 hours a week you can't
compete with that guy if some if you
yourself are reading two three four
books a month and you develop in your
mind and your competitor is not and he
only reads one or two and you study in
industry articles and all the subs and
they're not you know you're studying how
to recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should
network would what Kamino should I be a
part of who's the best engineers IT firm
to hire what are these competitors doing
what are some of the guys that are not
even in my market if you start studying
those industries somebody else isn't
it's tough to compete with you and then
outlast some people work 80 hours a week
for a year and that's great but they
can't work 80 hours a week for three
years some work 80 hours a week for
three years but you work 80 hours a week
for five years you outlasted the guy
that the three years are one year they
can't compete with you because the
compounding effort favors you so these
four things that you look at on the
screen require one thing and that's
discipline and the discipline part you
don't hear a lot about that's the things
people doing nobody will cease that's
when you win I do think that with an
it's not just in sport but with with
other things I do believe that the more
you repeat certain things whether it is
writing working on your you know whether
it's cursive letters or whatever it is
like when you work on something and you
keep doing it over and over it's
inevitable that it will get better and
by that you're creating this feeling of
repetition which leads to discipline
like you know you can do it over and
over again and that's one of my first
one of my first coaches Robert Lansdorp
who I speak about in the book like that
was his philosophy is you I would take a
lesson from him and his philosophy was
just hitting and grinding and it wasn't
about patterns or anything which you
know I could get from somebody else but
what he gave me is that feeling that I
could hit the ball from any part of the
court and feel like I could do it with
closed eyes and make it and know exactly
where it's going and for me it started
at a young age like my mom would would
make me memorize this Russian literature
that I did not appreciate at five years
old it was very difficult and I didn't
know what it meant but I would do it and
I would memorize it and then I would
feel that I accomplished something I
don't know why I don't know but the
repetition led me to this discipline and
and I think that helps with my son
lowers volume you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
kind of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details